[Music]
Jenna Dewan is bearing it all
the thirty-seven-year-old poses nude for
the September cover of women's health
and she's equally as revealing inside
the pages opening up about parenting her
five-year-old daughter Everly and
discovering her new identity after her
split from Channing Tatum Oh preciate
all the love Jenna tells the mag she's
been on a mission to find herself ever
since she and Chan split in April quote
I feel I've been on a wave of growth it
does look different it's a new normal
and I really think we'll get used to
that
[Music]
while the famous mama admits that big
changes are challenging especially when
the whole world has an opinion about it
she says her daughter will always come
first quote I think everyone wants to
hold on to what's in front of them but
when you open your mind saying I want
what's best for myself and my daughter
you have to be okay with however that
looks I was like do you girl do you
Jenna also admits that it's okay for a
relationship to change into a new form
adding quote I think that's maybe would
shocked everyone so much that it can be
a positive thing that was ultimately
what happened with us and the world of
dance star has a message for all the
haters who recently criticized her for
posting revealing pics on social media
she says she wants her daughter to see
that and be like wow my mother was a
fully actualized a sensual woman
[Music]
[Applause]